the holiday season is right around the  corner again so what better way to debut  markup liars debut singing career than  with his debut Christmas album filled  with classics like dreaming just like  the one you your icy cold stone I will  just melt when you hear his lyrical  lyrics sing through the snow collar  one-horse sleigh over the hills we go  laughing all the way ha ha ha ha ha  order now and a hundred percent of all  proceeds will be burned and sacrificed  to Santa Claus to keep him slumbering  from what  I love you you love me  [ __ ] so be sure to Hodor - Daris you're  gonna miss out for another year look at  the description below click it click it  now